je viens du club de mantes la jolie je
viens du karaté club de trappes je viens
du club du chesnay 250 karatékas venus
de 25 clubs du département ont participé
ce samedi 20 et dimanche 21 janvier aux
championnats des yvelines à plaisir la
compétition organisée tous les ans était
programmée pour la toute première fois
par le karaté club plaisir oit a en
premier une grande fierté parce que
c'est quand même un gros événement au
niveau du niveau du club une grosse
préparation en amour avec l'ensemble des
bénévoles qui font qu'ils viennent nous
aider pour organiser cet événement et
puis aussi pour pour l'équipe de se
montrer au niveau d'une des partants
parmi les concurrents 14 plaisir où
étaient inscrits pour cette compétition
à domicile l'occasion de magazines et de
l'expérience devant son public en vue
d'une qualification pour le championnat
régional où il faut gérer le stress
tout ça c'est le monde de la protection
avec le commentaire de sablage et
d'évoluer au niveau technique tactique
aussi c'est super important la tactique
et voilà aussi au niveau de la condition
physique
en fait plus on fait de la compétition
physiquement l'effort
la compétition s'est soldée par 12
podiums pur plaisir avec quatre titres à
la clé dont celui de chloé ménard dans
la catégorie des moins de 59 kg le club
envisage de renouveler l'organisation
d'un championnat des yvelines dans les
prochaines années